have you ever wondered how your email
provider implements spam filtering how
do online news channels perform news
text classification how do companies
perform sentiment analysis of Their
audience on social media with a machine
learning algorithms called na based
classifier you can do all of these
things hello everyone my name is mang
and welcome to this fantastic video on
the na based classifier in this video we
will delve into na based classifier
topics like what na Bas is the
advantages of nabas classifier
applications of Na Bas and understanding
of Na Bas and machine learning at the
end of this video we will Implement
Hands-On using nabas classifier so just
a quick info for you nabas is after all
an algorithm that is based on AI and
machine learning a professional who
wants to switch careers in Ai and ml by
learning from their expert then try
giving simply learn postgraduate program
in Ai and machine learning from part
University in collaboration with IBM in
this course you will learn in demand
skills such as machine learning deep
learning NLP computer vision
reinforcement learning generative AI
prompt engineering chat gbd and many
more the link in the description box
should navigate to the homepage where
you can find a complete overview of the
program being offered so take action
upskill and get ahead so without any
further Ado let's get started so what is
Nave base let's start with a basic
introduction to the base theorem named
after Thomas base the name base
classifier work on the principle of
conditional probability as given by the
base theorem the base theorem give us
the conditional probability of event a
given that event B has occurred so base
theorem calculates the conditional
probability of the occurrence of a event
based on prior knowledge of condition
that might be related to that event like
with any of our other machine learning
tools it is important to understand
where the na Bay fits in the hierarchy
so moving forward let's see some
advantages of Na base the first one is
it is simple and easy to implement the
second one is it doesn't require as much
straining data the third one is it
handles both continuous and discrete
data the fifth one is it is highly
scalable with the number of predictors
and the data points the sixth one is it
is fast and can be used to make realtime
prediction and the last one is it is not
sensitive to irrelevant features so
moving forward let's see some
application of n base the first one is
face recognition so as a classifier it
is used to identify the faces or its
other features like nose mouth eyes and
many others the second one is weather
prediction it can be used to predict if
the weather will be good or bad the
third one is medical diagnosis so doctor
can diagnose patient by using the
information that the classifier provides
Healthcare professional can use name Bas
to indicate if a patient is at at high
risk for a certain diseases and the
condition such as heart diseases cancer
and other elements the fourth one is
news classification with the help of n
based classifier Google News recognize
whether the news is political world news
and so on so as the na based classifier
has so many application it is worth
learning more about how it works so
let's see understanding of n bases and
machine learning machine learning falls
into two categories
supervised learning unsupervised
learning so supervised learning falls
into two categories classification and
regression so the na based algorithm
falls under classification problem so
moving forward let's jump into the demo
part so this is a Jupiter G notebook so
first we will Implement some or you can
say we will import some major libraries
right
import import pandas as PD
right okay Pand
SPD then we will
import
import numpy as NP then we will import
cbor as
SNS then we will
import M plot
lip do p plot
as
PLT okay then from Escalon dot
model
selection
import
train
test
split okay then from SK Lear dot
matrix
import
accuracy
score got it
then uh we will import classification
report as
well
import
sorry
from escalan do Matrix
import
classification
report okay uh then import R then import
string okay let me run it okay it's
still loading okay one cannot import
name train test split sorry my
bad
OKAY model
selection okay train test split it is
then Escalon do
matrix it's just a type of myri okay
guys classification report okay what's
the issue
here
okay
uh
yeah C must be small yeah everything is
fine now so now we will import data
set okay so I will add DF underscore
fake to pd. read uncore
CSV fake.
CSV
then same for the true. CSV so we have
two data set fake. CSV and true. CSV
okay you can download these data set
from the description box
below okay then let's check the fake
data
head this is our fake data
okay then we can check the true data as
well DF do true
do
head yes now you can check the true data
as well let me give me some spaces for
the better
visualization okay so now we will insert
a column class as the target feature
right so for that I will write DF
fake
class to zero okay then DF
fake sorry
true then
class = to
one okay and
DF
fake
okay press something
wrong yeah so DF uncore fake do shape
comma DF underscore through do
shape so as you can see in fake data set
we have 23481
23481 rows and the five column and in
true data set we have 2 sorry
21470 rows and the five you know columns
so now what we will
do we will remove last 10 rows from for
the manual testing okay or you can say
we are taking for the manual testing for
that I will write
DF
fake
manual testing equals to
DF fake do
tail
right
for for I
in range
2 3 4
80 comma 2 3 4 7
0 okay Min -
one
then DF dot sorry dfdore fake
dot
draw
I comma
XIs equal to 0 comma in
place = to
True
okay then for the manual testing for the
true data set as well it's quite
same okay just we have to change here
true
okay then
true it's
46 and here 2
1 41
6 right here I will change it to
True
okay okay
okay true.
tail okay one more
error 23 480 not found in the
AIS
okay okay
so for that what I will do I will copy
it basic
twice again some issue is there 2 3 480
not found in
Nexis
okay it's 2 3 4 8
1 4 not found in Nexis everything seems
fine now what I will do
DF
fake
manual
testing right then Target variable
class equals to zero then DF
true
manual
testing then
class = to one
okay just ignore this
right
now if I want to check
TF
fake
manual
testing.
head five
rows so as you can see these are the now
fake manual testing data right for the
manual testing so we can check for the
same for the true also true data set
okay let me check for the true data set
as
well just have to
write yes so this is for the true
okay yeah so I will write
here DF
manual
testing to PD do concave
con get the board data
set copy
it and paste it here
comma again and just here you have to
change it to
True okay then comma
XIs equals to Zer in the same AIS I want
then DF
manual
testing do
to
CSV
manual
testing.
CSC okay
access yeah right so here first I will
now merge true and the fake data frames
for
that I will write DF
merge equals to PD do
concat DF
fake comma DF
true and the same XIs equals to
zero okay then DF _
March do
head five rows I want to see so as you
can see okay we have merged the data
right so moving forward now we will
merge the column DF merge
dot
columns okay so these are the column
title text subject date and the
class okay okay so now removing column
which are not required so we don't
require the title subject and the date
so we can remove
them mar.
drop
then
title
comma
subject
date comma AIS = to
1 okay then DF dot is
null okay
DF
dot is
null do
sum okay fine so now what I will do I
will do
some random shuffling of the data frame
for that I will add DF
dot
sample flectional to
one then DF
dot okay sorry then DF do
head okay so these are our top five rows
so now I will
reset
index okay
what is
happening I will DF do
reset underscore
index in place equals to
true then DF do
drop
index X is = to 1
comma in
place first two
two
okay right then DF
dot columns so now we have only two
columns text column and the class column
class column is our Target column
right so
now what I will do DF do head you can
see see we have only text column the
class column 0 1 0 1 01 zero means fake
news and the one means True News okay
don't forget
it so now we will create a function to
process the text okay so I will write
the function and then get back to
you okay so this is our function wordp
text okay so text. lower and this is
what we write the question mark the
https right it will return only text
nothing like that then
DF
text equals to
text Dot
apply word
opt
okay
right then we will defining the
dependent and the independent variable
so for x equals to
DF then
text then yal to
DF class okay run
it then here what I will do I will split
the training and the testing data using
train test split function
xcore train comma xcore test comma
ycore train comma
Yore
testal to
train test
split then X comma y
comma
test size = to 0
.25
okay so now what we will do we will
convert text to vectors okay so
from scalar
dot
feature
extraction
dot text
import tfid
vectorizer
okay then I will write
factorization equals
to
tfid
vectorizer then XV
uncore
train
to
factorization dot fit
underscore
transform xcore
[Music]
train comma then XV uncore
test to
same okay I have to just remove this fit
and here I have to write
test
okay spelling is wrong I
guess here also
wrong yeah so everything is fine so now
I will
first load the logistic regression then
we will implement the na base okay so
from skarn do
linear model
import
logistic
regression okay then LR equals
to
logistic
regression then LR dot
fit
XV train comma
y
train okay it's linear
model yeah so it will take some time to
load till then we okay it's run we can
write
prediction
LR equals to LR dot
predict XV
test okay then I will write here
lr.
score then
XV underscore test comma y underscore
test okay so as you can see our LR score
is 98 so accuracy is 98% which is very
good so here I want to print
classification report as
well
classification
report of yore
test comma prediction
LR okay so so we will do same for the n
as well so for
that I will write from
Escalon do na
base
import
balii
NB right then NB equals to
butly
NB
right then NB do
fit then
XV uncore train
comma Yore
train okay yeah so the same I want to
copy it from here then I will paste it
here so instead of LR will come NB and
here it will come NB
here it will come and B that's it so as
you can see our na base prediction is
accuracy is
94% and I want to write classification
put we can copy it and paste it here and
just change
here
NB okay so moving forward what what we
will do now we will do the model testing
the final thing
right okay so I will write the code and
the get back to you okay so I wrote this
for the random for classifier and the
dec classifier as well so now I have one
news I took it from the internet you can
take any type of news so it's a fake
news right okay then see as you can see
all our you know models are predicting
right fake news you can try at you can
try with the any news right you can just
Google it just take out any news from it
and copy paste it here and just check
whether it is predicting right or wrong
so with that we have come to end of this
video I hope you like this video if you
have any query please ask in the comment
section below our team of expert will
help you as soon as possible thank you
and keep learning with simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here